one thing about this tournament is that
it has a lot of volunteers now tell us a
bit about yourself my name is Andrei and
I am a volunteer here
I know it is a great tournament and I
wanted to be here to see the so many
good players and great matches and I am
very happy to be here do you play chess
as well or do you enjoy watching it as a
fan what is your experience with us yes
I play chess for 10 years 10 years now
since I was six years old and I have a
lot of experience and
that was also great for me you've been
playing chess for quite a long time why
would you say your level is
buying medium but I want to be good as
the
I want to be good to improve yes yes
for time to time no I know month
here yes yes and definitely being in the
presence of this like great chess
players will help you improve as well
your style what would you say is
comparable to which player you think is
comparable
I think firoza
because I admire him for a long time
because he is very young and when your
Grandmaster at a good age it is a
pleasure to you and I think my
I play like him thank you very much for
joining us it was a pleasure and thank
you for helping as a volunteer thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign